The Princess Bride contains a few
elements that when watching it as an
adult make you tilt your head and go
wait what even if you loved the film as
so many people do here are some of the
weird things in The Princess Bride that
you only notice as an adult have fun
storming the castle perhaps you wanted
the eagle-eyed view that first noticed
this as a child but most of us glossed
right over the fact that the Princess
Bride is set during the Christmas season
Santa Claus decorations are scattered
throughout the grandsons messy room most
notably the one hanging behind the
grandfather on the closet door plus
there's a tabletop tree decorated with
lights visible through the bedroom door
and when the mother throws open the
grandsons curtains a snow-covered
rooftop lined with lights can be spotted
outside the window even The Princess
Bride book itself as a Christmas gift
it's given to the grandson wrapped in
cheery Santa paper at first glance
there's nothing to miss about the scene
in which Buttercup tries to escape from
Pezzini Fezzik and an eagle Montoya by
jumping off their ship and attempting to
swim to safety she starts to swim to the
unidentified ship in the distance but
stops when she hears the screeches of
the shrieking eels Vizzini offers her
the chance to swim back to safety then
Bezeq clunks the eel on top of its head
with a bowling ball-sized fist and
scoops a shaken but uninjured Buttercup
up out of the water everything in the
scene tracks until you realize that
Buttercup never actually swam back to
the boat she swam away for a few solid
strokes putting her about half a pool
length away from the boats but then she
just beautifully treaded water until
Pesek punched the eel and pulled her
back into the ship since the boats
apparently never changed course the only
way for the scene to have happened is if
Essex arms suddenly stretched to a
ridiculously long length of probably at
least eight feet he might be a giant but
he's not that much of a giant this is
probably just a continuity error but
it's fun to imagine an explanation isn't
it busy knees plan once his boat reaches
the cliffs of insanity is simple physic
will carry his party up the sheer face
of the cliffs using the Rope dangling
down from the top and then they'll press
on into Gilder kill Buttercup and start
a war when they arrive at the base of
the cliffs a triumphant Vizzini
proclaims that it doesn't matter that
the ship behind them is nearly caught up
with them as he explains
holy physic is strong enough to go
Hardaway you'll have to sail around for
hours till he finds a harbor accept the
fact that the rope is there implies that
the Seanie has already been to this
location and tied the rope at the top to
prepare for this part of the plan to do
that he probably used the very Farber
he's claiming the other ship can't
possibly know about what's more the
castle ruins at the top seem to imply
that at one point this was a well
traveled destination meaning that the
location of the harbor shouldn't be such
a mystery this raises two questions one
why didn't Pezzini just used the harbor
to begin with since he clearly knew
where it was and - why would he assume
no one else had that knowledge
everything about the cliffs of insanity
sequence in The Princess Bride is
undeniably thrilling from the race up
the face of the cliffs to Wesley's
ability to cling to the rocks instead of
falling however when you consider the
shots of Wesley climbing mere seconds
before Vizzini slices the rope and it
doesn't make sense that he was able to
grab on to the rock face and the moment
he felt the Rope begin to slip Wesley
would have had to swing on the rope and
jump on to the rocks to have a chance at
winding up in the position we eventually
find him in even if there was enough
time for him to have done this between
shots why woody he was making much
better time on the rope than he does on
the rocks as an additional layer of
mystery how did Wesley's boots become so
full of rocks once he reached the top
and every shot we saw of Wesley climbing
the rope his legs were kickin freely in
the open air far from the rocks what was
he doing in the few seconds when the
camera wasn't on him that not only
enabled him to grab onto the rock face
but fill his boots with stones we may
never know when Wesley eventually
reaches the tops of the cliffs of
insanity an ego graciously offers him a
chance to catch his breath before they
start their duel while this seems
motivated by honor an ego may have also
had a selfish motive shortly before this
moment Denis go tells masini that he'll
be fighting left-handed in order to make
the duel last longer allowing Wesley
time to recover may have been in service
of the same goal with an ego finding
little satisfaction and using up less
time besting a winded opponent however
there's another indication of an ego
sense of honour in the seat one which
could have proven deadly by telling the
story of his father's murder an ego
hands Wesley his only weapon without
hesitation before their duel it Wesley
had less integrity than an ego he could
have killed him right then and there
while he was unarmed and defenseless
that it didn't seem to occur to either
swordsman to behave less than honorably
in this moment
makes volumes about the kinds of
characters they are and it's why we root
for both of them as a child it may have
been difficult to make out every line of
dialogue during physics fight with
Wesley given that both participants
spend most of the scene significantly
exerting themselves and occasionally
choking however if you can catch all of
physics lines you may be left wanting a
lot more information about his life
before he came to work for fizzy Mia at
first when Fezzik offers to fight Wesley
in hand-to-hand combat he explains that
he hates for people to die embarrassed
just who is Fezzik seemed I embarrassed
and what exactly was his role in their
deaths he also tells Wesley when
explaining why he's had so much trouble
fighting a single opponent that is more
used to groups specifically battling
gangs for charity it's hard to simply
skate past the fact that Fezzik spaz
seems to have included significant
mercenary work for neighborhood
nonprofits well no one wants a Princess
Bride remake we wouldn't turn up our
noses at a prequel exploring precisely
which causes these local charities in
Greenland were championing that required
them to have their own one-man brute
squad the battle of wits in which Hasini
talks in circles until finally die in
mid triumphant laugh from a sip of
alkane poison wine is one of the most
iconic scenes in a film made up almost
entirely of iconic scenes so it's easy
to miss that the picnic laid out in
front of a scene he makes almost no
sense
Hasini wasn't carrying anything when he
departed the boat and took the Fezzik
elevator up the cliffs of insanity and
he didn't appear to have any supplies
waiting for him at the top so where did
he get the two goblets bottle of wine to
apples block of cheese hunk of bread and
a cheese knife not to mention the
tablecloth it was all laid out on did he
just have it all set up on a random rock
ready to go
and if so why was Bhasin he somehow so
clever that he knew in advance that
Wesley would beat his enforcers and join
him for lunch it's always suppose he was
right after all
we really shouldn't go up against the
Sicilian when death is on the line
disco is one of the most portable lines
in The Princess Bride but when you think
about it it's not a very reasonable
mantra to live by when Wesley asked why
Buttercup didn't wait for him she
responds very practically that he was
dead remember he was gone for five
entire years and pronounced dead at some
point during that time knowing that her
chance to marry for love died with
Wesley Buttercup instead agreed to an
arranged marriage with a prince however
according to Wesley she should have kept
right on way
friend despite his years long absence
and legally declared death according to
his logic the only course of action
acceptable for a woman who's lost a
partner is to remain faithful forever
and unmarried for the rest of her life
put like that it's a wonder that
Buttercup didn't drag him up that hill
just so she could push him back down
again probably one of the most memorable
scenes in the Princess Bride his
buttercups Knight Mara being publicly
booed for the choices she's made
throughout the film such as her
agreement to marry Humperdinck if
Wesley's life is spared buttercup is
plagued by the fear that she's done the
wrong thing and as a child it's easy to
agree with her swept up in the romantic
notion that she should have dug in her
heels and refused to compromise her
ideals but as an adult it's easier to
see that Buttercup may be unfairly
maligned throughout the film Buttercup
shows a lot of courage keeping her cool
throughout multiple abductions
repeatedly refusing to be bulldozed by
the powerful Prince Humperdinck and
suggesting strategies to resolve
conflict that would minimize bloodshed
as a woman from a modest farm Buttercup
wouldn't hold much power but she uses
what leverage she does have two sub
lists rike a bargain that she believes
will keep Wesley safe at great cost to
herself it's only once she believes she
secured Wesley's freedom that she
finally unleashes her true opinions on
Humperdinck at last she pushes back
against his dismissal of her yes for not
having seen sooner that she would miss
able to cowered with a heart full of
fear all hail Queen Buttercup indeed
when an ego gets the idea to ask Wesley
to help him plan his Castle attack
defining kill count Rugen Ian Fezzik
follow Wesley screams to the Grove
hiding the entrance to the pit of
despair there they encounter the albino
Rogen's minion who maintains the pits in
his absence an ego a sea albino where
they can find the man in black but the
albino seems too shaken to say anything
any go ask Fezzik to jog his memory and
Fezzik gives the albino a heavy blow on
top of the head
the albino collapses into his
wheelbarrow and Bezeq apologizes for
hitting him too hard watching the scene
as a kid it's easy to assume Fezzik
merely knocked the albino out but
watching it as an adult it becomes clear
that the albino is likely dead the blow
he takes to the head looks extremely
forceful and his eyes remain open as he
keels over even if the old bino didn't
die right away Bezeq and annie go leave
him there without medical attention
making it likely that the severe head
trauma he suffered would eventually lead
to death
after spending the whole film building
up to it Inigo Montoya's final showdown
with count Rugen is nothing short of
spectacular it's got a chase scene that
spans much of the castle a moment of
devastating doubt when rügen catches an
ego in the stomach with a throw dagger
and more it all builds to a thrill of
tremendous triumph when Inigo rallies
and kills count Rugen repeatedly
shouting the line he's been preparing to
deliver since he was 11
[Music]
after count Rugen dies and ego heads off
to find the rest of his group and he's
offered the position of Dread Pirate
Roberts by Wesley before the four heroes
head off on white horses but chances are
good that an ego had never lived to
explore an exciting new career in piracy
he suffered precisely the same wounds as
count Rugen which proved fatal for the
six-fingered man
Inigo managed to win his duel but it was
likely adrenaline that allowed him to
ignore his wounds and keep fighting
once the foursome was out of danger and
and egos adrenaline wore off he likely
tumbled off his white horse and died of
blood loss
trust us we don't want this any more
than you do being an adult is hard check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]